I've got several fun things for you this
video an unsolved problem a very elegant
solution to a weaker version of the
problem and a little bit about what
topology is and why people care but
Before we jump into it it's worth saying
a few words on why I'm excited to share
this solution when I was a kid since I
loved math and sought out various
Matthew things I would occasionally find
myself in some talk or a seminar where
people wanted to get the youth excited
about things that mathematicians care
about a very common go-to topic to
excite our imaginations was topology we
might be shown something like a mobius
strip maybe building it out of
construction paper by twisting a
rectangle and gluing its ends look we'd
be told as we were asked to draw a line
along the surface it's a surface with
just one side or we might be told that
topologists view coffee mugs and donuts
as the same thing since each has just
one hole but these kinds of demos always
left a lurking question how is this math
how does any of this actually help to
solve problems it wasn't until I saw the
problem that I'm about to show you with
its elegant and surprising solution that
I started to understand why
mathematicians actually care about some
of these shapes and the properties they
have so there's this unsolved problem
called the inscribed square problem if
you have a closed loop
meaning you squiggle some line through
space in a potentially crazy way and you
end up back where you started
the question is whether or not you'll
always be able to find four points on
this loop that make up a square if your
closed loop was a circle for example
it's quite easy to find an inscribed
square infinitely many in fact
if your loop was instead an ellipse it's
still pretty easy to find an inscribed
square the question is whether or not
every possible closed loop no matter how
crazy has at least one inscribed square
pretty interesting right I mean just the
fact that this is unsolved is
interesting that the current tools of
math can neither confirm nor deny that
there's some loop with no inscribed
square in it now if we weaken the
question a bit and ask about inscribed
rectangles instead of inscribed squares
it's still pretty hard but there is a
beautiful video worthy solution that
might actually be my favorite piece of
math the idea is to shift the focus away
from individual points on the loop and
instead on two pairs of points will use
the following fact about rectangles
let's label the vertices of some
rectangle a b c d then the pair of
points a c has a few things in common
with a pair of points b d the distance
between a and C equals the distance
between B and D and the midpoint of a
and C is the same as the midpoint of B
and D in fact anytime you have two
separate pairs of points in space AC and
BD if you can guarantee that they share
a midpoint and that the distance between
AC equals the distance between B and D
it's enough to guarantee that those four
points make up a rectangle so what we're
gonna do is try to prove that for any
closed loop it's always possible to find
two distinct pairs of points on that
loop that share a midpoint and which are
the same distance apart take a moment to
make sure that's clear we're finding two
distinct pairs of points that share a
common midpoint and which are the same
distance apart
the way we'll go about this is to define
a function that takes in pairs of points
on the loop and outputs a single point
in 3d space which kind of encodes the
midpoint and distance information it
will be sort of like a graph
consider the closed loop to be sitting
on the XY plane in 3d space for a given
pair of points label their midpoint M
which will be some point on the XY plane
and label the distance between them D
plot the point which is exactly D units
above that midpoint M in the Z Direction
as you do this for many possible pairs
of points you'll effectively be drawing
through 3d space and if you do it for
all possible pairs of points on the loop
you'll draw out some kind of surface
above the plane now look at the surface
and notice how it seems to hug the loop
itself this is actually going to be
important later so let's think about why
it happens as the pair of points on the
loop gets closer and closer the plotted
point gets lower since its height is by
definition equal to the distance between
the points also the midpoint gets closer
and closer to the loop as the points
approach each other once the pair of
points coincides meaning the input of
our function looks like X X for some
point X on the loop the plotted point of
the surface will be exactly on the loop
at the point X okay so remember that
another important fact is that this
function is continuous and all that
really means is that if you slightly
adjust a given pair of points then the
corresponding output in 3d space is only
slightly adjusted as well there's never
a sudden discontinuous jump our goal
then is to show that this function has a
collision that two distinct pairs of
points each map to the same spot in 3d
space because the only way for that to
happen is if they share a common
midpoint and if their distance D apart
from each other is the same so in some
sense
finding an inscribed rectangle comes
down to showing that this surface has to
intersect itself
to move forward from here we need to
build up a relationship with the idea of
pairs of points on a loop think about
how we represent pairs of real numbers
using a two-dimensional coordinate plane
analogous to this we're going to seek
out a certain 2d surface which naturally
represents all pairs of points on the
loop understanding the properties of
this surface will help to show why the
graph that we just defined has to
intersect itself
now when I say pair of points there are
two things that I could be talking about
the first is ordered pairs of points
which would mean a pair like a B would
be considered distinct from the pair B a
that is there's some notion of which
point is the first one the second idea
is unordered points where a B and B a
would be considered the same thing where
all that really matters is what the
points are and there's no meaning to
which one is first ultimately we want to
understand unordered pairs of points but
to get there we need to take a path of
thought through ordered pairs
we'll start out by straightening out the
loop cutting it at some point and
deforming it into an interval for the
sake of having some labels let's say
that this is the interval on the number
line from 0 to 1 by following where each
point ends up every point on the loop
corresponds with a unique number on this
interval except for the point where the
cut happened which corresponds
simultaneously to both endpoints of the
interval meaning the number 0 and 1 now
the benefit of straightening out this
loop like this is that we can start
thinking about pairs of points the same
way we think about pairs of numbers
make a y-axis using a second interval
then associate each pair of values on
the interval with a single point in this
1x1 square that they span out every
individual point of this square
naturally corresponds to a pair of
points on the loop since its x and y
coordinates are each numbers between 0
and 1 which are in turn associated to
some unique point on the loop remember
we're trying to find a surface that
naturally represents the set of all
pairs of points on the loop and this
square is the first step to doing that
the problem is that there's some
ambiguity when it comes to the edges of
the square remember the end points 0 & 1
on the interval really correspond to the
same point of the loop as if to say that
those endpoints need to be glued
together if we're going to faithfully
map back to the loop so all of the
points on the left edge of the square
like 0 0 point 1 0 0 point 2 on and on
and on really represent the same pair of
points on the loop as the corresponding
coordinates on the right edge of the
square one zero point one one zero point
two on and on and on so for this square
to represent the pairs of points on the
loop in a unique way
we need to glue this left edge to the
right edge I'll mark each edge with some
arrows to remember how the edges need to
be lined up likewise the bottom edge
needs to be glued to the top edge since
y-coordinates of 0 & 1 really represent
the same second point in a given pair of
points on the loop
bend the square to perform the gluing
first rolling it into a cylinder to glue
the left and right edges then gluing the
ends of that cylinder which represent
the top and bottom edges we get a Taurus
better known as the surface of a donut
every individual point on this torus
corresponds to a unique pair of points
on the loop and likewise every pair of
points on the loop corresponds to some
unique point on this torus the torus is
two pair of points on the loop what the
XY plane is two pairs of points on the
real number line the key property of
this Association is that it's continuous
both ways
meaning if you nudge any point on the
torus by just a tiny amount it
corresponds to only a very slight nudge
to the pair of points on the loop and
vice-versa so if the torus is the
natural shape for ordered pairs of
points on the loop what's the natural
shape for unordered pairs after all the
whole reason we're doing this is to show
that two distinct pairs of points on the
loop share a midpoint and are the same
distance apart
but if we consider a pair a B to be
distinct from BA then that would
trivially give us two separate pairs
which have the same midpoint and
distance apart that's like saying you
can always find a rectangle so long as
you consider any pair of points to be a
rectangle not helpful so let's think
about this
let's think about how to represent
unordered pairs of points looking back
at our unit square we need to say that
the coordinates 0.2 0.3 represent the
same pair as 0.3 0.2 or that 0.5 0.7
really represents the same thing as 0.7
0.5 and in general any coordinates X Y
has to represent the same thing as Y X
once again we capture this idea by
gluing points together when they're
supposed to represent the same pair
which in this case requires folding the
square over diagonally now notice this
diagonal line the crease of the fold it
represents all pairs of points that look
like X X meaning the pairs which are
really just a single point written twice
right now it's marked with a red line
and you should remember it it will
become important to know where all of
these pairs like XX live but we still
have some arrows to glue together here
we need to glue that bottom edge to the
right edge and the orientation with
which we do this is going to be
important points towards the left of the
bottom edge have to be glued to points
towards the bottom of the right edge and
points towards the right of the bottom
edge have to be glued to points towards
the top of the right edge it's weird to
think about right go ahead pause and
ponder this for a moment
the trick which is kind of clever
is to make a diagonal cut which we need
to remember to glue back in just a
moment after that we can glue the bottom
and the right like so but notice the
orientation of the arrows here to glue
back what we just cut we don't simply
connect the edges of this rectangle to
get a cylinder we have to make a twist
doing this in 3d space the shape we get
is a mobius strip
isn't that awesome evidently the surface
which represents all pairs of unordered
points on the loop is the mobius strip
and notice the edge of the strip shown
here in red represents the pairs of
points that look like X X those which
are really just a single point listed
twice the mobius strip is two unordered
pairs of points on the loop what the XY
plane is two pairs of real numbers
that totally blew my mind when I first
saw it
now with this fact that there is a
continuous one-to-one association
between unordered pairs of points on the
loop and individual points on this
mobius strip we can solve the inscribed
rectangle problem remember we had to
find this special kind of graph in 3d
space where the loop was sitting in the
XY plane for each pair of points you
consider their midpoint M which lives on
the XY plane and their distance D apart
and you plot a point which is exactly D
units above M because of the continuous
one-to-one Association between pairs of
points on the loop and the mobius strip
this gives us a natural map from the
mobius strip onto this surface in 3d
space for every point on the mobius
strip
consider the pair of points on the loop
that it represents then plug that pair
of points into the special function and
here's the key point
when pairs of points on the loop are
extremely close together the output of
the function is right above the loop
itself and in the extreme case of pairs
of points like X X the output of the
function is exactly on the loop since
points on this red edge of the mobius
strip correspond to pairs like X X when
the mobius strip is mapped on to this
surface it must be done in such a way
that the edge of the strip gets mapped
right on to that loop in the XY plane
but if you stand back and think about it
for a moment considering the strange
shape of the Mobius strip there is no
way to glue its edge to something
two-dimensional without forcing the
strip to intersect itself
since points of the Mobius trip
represent pairs of points on the loop if
the strip intersect itself during this
mapping it means that there are at least
two distinct pairs of points that
correspond to the same output on this
surface which means they share a
midpoint and are the same distance apart
which in turn means that they form a
rectangle and that's the proof or at
least if you're willing to trust me in
saying that you can't glue the edge of a
mobius strip to a plane without forcing
it to intersect itself then that's the
proof
this fact is intuitively clear looking
at the mobius strip but in order to make
it rigorous you basically need to start
developing the field of topology in fact
for any of you who have a topology class
in your future going through the
exercise of trying to justify this is a
good way to gain an appreciation for why
topologists choose to make certain
definitions and I want you to take note
of something here the reason for talking
about the Taurus and the Mobius trip was
not because we were playing around with
construction paper or because we were
daydreaming about deforming a coffee mug
they came up as a natural way to
understand pairs of points on a loop and
that's something that we needed to solve
a concrete problem
[Music]